what else is up dude i mean so much i
mean i'll tell you what's up that
[ __ ] moose that got hit by that
minivan i didn't see that oh but i heard
someone
yeah i know
i but i saw some people like sending it
to me but i didn't click on it well it's
it you didn't see it cause like you're
upset with twitter right
like you just can't handle yeah exactly
yeah yeah the he she what moose you sons
of yeah yeah yeah
you know you see that moose i got hit by
that no i won't moose you sons of
[ __ ] i will not adhere to the he she
they them
what moose
it's time for animal murder
we should actually do a jingle
yeah like that animal death this caption
yeah dude this [ __ ] yo stops first of
all oh this moose hit the nastiest slide
cancel
[Laughter]
throw 5 000 views
homie nah this is not the main one oh
okay but let it rip
yo bunny bro
it's not funny bro
holy [ __ ]
oh my god it really did slide cancel
right into it it's getting owned
one more time just to make sure it's not
funny
dude the car is [ __ ] up
was that a pt cruiser no no way pt
cruiser with have [ __ ] crumpled
wasn't it
no
no dude that's that's a hundred percent
uh
that's gotta be japanese engineering
the ragdoll dude it's unreal that poor
moose it literally looks like a bat
did it die
um
i don't know like the person in the car
did not
okay
that happens all the time though when
people hit moose
meese mises they die they die yeah
yeah they're like 5 000 pounds oh [ __ ]
that is like going into a brick wall
yeah
oh now you made it not funny
no but this didn't look that bad yeah i
don't play it one more time
yeah let's make sure they're okay
yeah they seem fun
man that's so horrible just hit it one
more time
i can't even watch it hit it one more
time
i will pass out if we keep watching this
dude
i don't want to keep watching because
it's so horrible yeah just dancing in
the air just
bro
let that let it rotate let it rotate one
more time
you know the way it hits the ground
afterward it just
it's so [ __ ] up
it's messed up how that's not funny who
could ever find that funny oh
god
i love how many people tagged us in that
yeah
yo yo yo yo
and if you ever see more videos like
that
you know just don't even bother i mean
you can send them to us but like we
don't want to see them yeah make sure
that no make sure we know what they are
so we can see how
absolutely not funny that is yeah
the original one sent to me has 195 000
likes and that's everyone who listens to
this podcast oh so wow yeah so that went
crazy oh yeah and well there are other
people that enjoy it
that's what i'm saying he went dummy
viral yeah okay yeah no i mean i'm
pretty sure all the listeners of this
podcast oh [ __ ] okay this one's a more
complete version
he
dude he hit that with like a renault
clio
look up that car he may not be dead but
he may not have toes anymore dog
i think it was that it looked bigger no
no no no it's it's that and this version
i got oh yeah that's a small car yeah
that's the same that car is
where it is where is this
it's gotta be like estonia or some [ __ ]
are there moves in it i don't know it's
probably it could be russia
yo this is the full is it booking it out
of the woods it is ah 8 24's next movie
right here
when nature
yo moose
he dropped it down in the middle of the
street are you kidding
are you kidding
he's fully in motion and then he hears
one honk and
they shouldn't have honked at him i mean
it's yeah you think that's why he slide
canceled yeah he
he fully does
he fully it's not right when they honk
though his controller battery dies right
here look
no it's way after he sees the
[Music]
to think that to think that a moose
would hear a honk and know how to
process it yeah like we've been
conditioned to learn that that is that
means stop or something's wrong oh i i
was thinking because it's loud so maybe
it got like oh danger oh yeah you know
because they say when you see big
animals you have to act big so i thought
maybe oh he thought they were cheering
for him yeah he's like hey
[Laughter]
no he's used to hearing that honk when
people pull over and like feed him
carrots and [ __ ] no
food
oh wait where's the food you know
so
that's so [ __ ]
damn
that one's crazy donates kidney to dying
boyfriend and then he cheats on her
[ __ ]
help that's bad what is this moose flip
freestyle
moose one thing for sure i know this
moose not moving on
moose like what the [ __ ] is going on i
know he was just trying to eat some lung
minivan turned the moose to a blast i'm
like
[Music]
mitsubishi all right
damn it's kind of trash
if you're gonna do a freestyle about a
moose death no that was hilarious no no
that was hilarious you're out of your
mind
um that was objectively hysterical was
it that was funny you didn't really
laugh that hard i i laughed and then i'm
think i'm processing it now dude he's
rapping over i believe i can fly then he
has a beat switch come on yeah yeah
is moose thinking what the [ __ ] going on
that's just that's funny
that's a funny ass line
it's hard as hell yeah okay you're right
jesus christ
you